en tant que mentalist je m'intéresse
beaucoup aux petits détails qui se
trouvent autour de nous chacune des
actions que l'on prend décision que l'on
entreprend laisse derrière soi des
piscines qui nous permettent de déduire
ce qui s'est passé commande objectif
après un crime le 10e rang sur la scène
et analysent tous les petits indices qui
peut y trouver comme des empreintes
digitales des miettes de pain etc
c'est pareil pour moi je m'appelle
tamansourt et à côté de mes études
d'ingénieur je suis un détective de la
pensée à chaque fois que vous avez une
pensée dans votre esprit vous laissez
passer des petits signes qui me
permettent de revenir à votre pensée
initiale
laissez-moi vous illustrez ceux ci
voulaient me rejoindre sur scène s'il
vous plaît on applaudit bien fort
rassurez vous tout va bien se passer
enchantée vous êtes ça on chantait ça
rame comme si on passait la première
fois qu'on se voit sara je vais vous
demander de penser à nos plaies quelque
chose de simple que pour aider ce n'est
pas une forme géométrique quelque chose
du genre mais juste quelque chose que
tout le monde pourrait reconnaître ne me
le dit pas juste garder ça dans votre
tête
non juste un objet ou quelque chose de
simple je veux pas non plus des trucs
très spécifique genre un avion f 12 de
l'anr voilà un truc voir esprit large
savoir je vous avais quelque chose en
tête serge concentrez-vous là dessus
c'est de l'imaginer devant vous ok je
vois déjà des formes rondes circulaire
peut-être un peu cylindrique quelque
chose qui monte avec quelque chose de
poser par dessus vous pouvez l'imaginer
dans un contexte quelle joie du blanc
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une sorte de
de lumière qui passe quelque part
peut-être un côté transparent ou un côté
qui réfléchit la lumière ne me dit rien
j'ai l'impression qu'il est assez lisse
et pages en un cactus ou quelque chose
du genre il ya vraiment un côté très
haut avant que j'oublie je vais vous
inviter à l'écrire juste ici comme ça
vous pouvez pas changer d'avis vous
pouvez utiliser la table juste ici
d'ailleurs pouvez aussi mettre votre
prénom et la date comme ça vous êtes sûr
que c'est la même chose
bon je vous rassure ceux ci est aussi
pour vous protéger contre moi
si jamais j'insiste inutilement avec que
c'est faux que bon on pourra vérifier à
la fin mais normalement n'auraient pas
besoin de l'utiliser parce que ça
devrait fonctionner donc et rivaux
freinant la date est l'objet de manière
bien vise pas de gribouiller c'est bon
on pouvait au pied très bien donc ceci
c'est un peu une protection on va dire
ok de sa juste laissé sa juste là comme
ça on va y revenir vous concentrez vous
là dessus j'aimerais revenir à un point
qui marquait bien cette espèce de cercle
a envoyé à un endroit d'un il ya un trou
c'est ça que je voyais concentrez-vous
là dessus visualisez c'est bien dans
votre esprit pouvez l'utiliser l'objet
c'est très bizarre pouvez l'utiliser
ok donc essayer de l'imaginer en train
de l'utiliser il ya vaudois qui bouge un
peu
c'est quelque chose de très tactique ok
d'accord c'est bien comme ça
détendez vous rassurer vous qui j'ai
l'impression que c'est quelque chose de
très tactique effectivement des formes
un peu ronde comme ça c'est très bizarre
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi je vois ça
mais j'ai l'impression que vous posez
pas des choses sur le ring c'est l'objet
qui est posée sur vous ouais ok c
concentrez-vous là dessus vous pouvez
l'imaginer en train de l'utiliser
je peux prendre vos bras merci
montrez-vous là dessus mais c'est juste
le mouvement venir ne fait rien juste eu
veut
je veux vraiment ça ait un côté très
beau un côté très élégant c'est un
instrument
ok ça doit être ça vous êtes musicien ou
pas non pas du tout mais mais c'est
quelque chose quand même qui vous
inspirent vos tripes c'est extrêmement
beau vous mêmes vous visualisez un monde
et la première fois où vous l'auriez
c'est un violon oui on la veut ne vient
pas merci beaucoup et revenir à votre
place
c'est toujours comme ça les grands
événements joint toujours des plus
infimes mais et si les petits événements
pouvaient en engendrer de plus important
imaginez par exemple des empreintes
digitales et des miettes de pain n'ont
pas aidé à résoudre un crime mais en
être la cause
absurde n'est ce pas ou peut-être pas
regarder l'effet papillon un simple
papillon battant ses ailes au brésil
d'engendrer une tornade au texas
nan regarder le point de vue du pape sy
il ne faisait que vivre sa vie
tranquillement sans se douter du fait
qu'ils étaient en train de causer une
catastrophe naturelle à l'autre bout du
monde
et si c'était pareil pour nous et si
nous n'étions pas conscients de l'impact
de nos actes les plus infimes les plus
naturelles cela fait cinq ans que je
suis fascinée obsédé par une idée nous
faisons des choix tout le long de notre
vie tous les jours et si chacun de ses
choix aussi infime soit il avait une
conséquence sur notre entourage voire
même sur des personnes qu'on ne connaît
pas vous êtes vous déjà demandé ce qui
se serait passé si vous aviez tourné à
gauche plutôt qu'à droite
voyant cela pour commencer nous allons
laisser le chaos faire bien les choses
je vais lancer cette petite balle dans
le public et la personne qui la rattrape
été invités à se mettre debout à me
rejoindre
alors ne passez pas la balle à votre
voisin j'ai déjà vu ça plusieurs fois
façon il y aura des témoins up là haut
up battre et vous pouvez la relance et
si vous voulez très bien et j'ai vu un
veston ok on applaudit bien fort nous
aimerions très saine
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous êtes alex n enchante et
alexey alekseev je vais vous demander de
penser à un nombre entre 1 et 50 de sa
sera votre numéro de chance ok je vais
vous donner ça je vous invite et
d'écrire juste ici et de vous installer
juste là pouvez vous installer sur la
chaise très bien et sinon nous aurons
nous allons avoir besoin d'une autre
personne tenez vous madame vous m'avez
l'air bien on va vous passez des des
crayons et des post it et vous allez oui
mais vous allez vous devoir vous
déplacez vous allez donner un post it et
un crayon à quatre personnes dans la
salle pour n'aller pas au fond parce que
on est un peu limité par le temps juste
rester un peu à côté d'où oui un crayon
et un post it
d'ailleurs comment vous appelez-vous
pour tout le monde elena on applaudit
bien fort les lun n'allez pas trop loin
quand même s'il vous plaît je la voit
s'éloigner au farm monsieur c'est bon
chaque personne qui reçoit un post it et
un crayon est invité à écrire son prénom
là tu es ce que le seul eux scotchés sur
le torse au et devenir sa ligne est
juste là oui chaque post it crayon très
bien oui il pouvait vous mettre en ligne
juste ici ah oui vous vous amusez
vraiment henin et pour terminer au
jamais vu quelqu'un s'amuse et au poids
l es en train de sentir les personnes
donc écrivez votre maison il vous aider
à vous et me rejoindre sur scène aussi
vous allez avant un rôle extrêmement
important ce soir il faut est passée par
là vous pouvez rester juste en bas merci
vous allez venir dans un instant on
applaudit en corée du nord
[Applaudissements]
et je vous en prie lna mais c'est vous
d'abord enchanté vous allez vous
installer juste là vous avez une chaise
juste faux pauvres et les menaces ce
soir vous allez avoir un rôle assez
incroyable car vous allez jouer le rôle
du chaos
amusant n'est ce pas ça va très bien au
québec vous allez commencer par faire
exactement ce que le chaos aime bien
faire c'est à dire battre les cartes
exactement que vous le fait
magnifiquement quand vous aurez terminé
vous pouvez les laisser justice donc
nous avons quatre personnes ce soir nous
avons pouvez me dire votre prénom julie
carle très bien amélie et marie par mon
mari rené merci bien vous avez terminé
oui vous faites vraiment un gros amusez
vous et après vous pouvez l'essayer
l'écart justice et je vais vous
expliquer ce qu'il va se passer chacun
d'entre vous dans un instant vous allez
monter sur scène et vous allez faire
votre plus beau défilé de mode juste ici
et vous installé sur n'importe quelle
chose que vous voulez autour de cette
table et vous d'ailleurs alex n c'est
bien ça vous ne savez pas trop ce qui va
se passer mais sachez que chaque chose
qui va se passer sur scène va vous
intacte et voilà je laisse ça l'a donc
vous avez terminé très bien et donc vous
vous allez tous les regarder et vous
allez décider qui permet à fait le plus
beau ou le plus moche on va laisser le
critère entre nous comme ça y'a pas de
jaloux défilé de mode
et quand ils auront tous terminés on
refera les prêts non rassurez-vous vous
allez écrire un et un seul prénom en
grand ici pour qu'on montre ça à la fin
ça marche quand ils seront tout se
passait bien sûr donc nous commençons
par julie je vous en prie
allez-y montée montrez nous vos talents
oui en la courage oui oui faites et vous
installez vous voulez oui
ensuite nous allons vous allez vous
montez annoncé votre nom à haute voix et
fait le cas très bien oui les installer
ou et c'était très direct très sobre
mais n'empêche quelques subtilités là
dedans c'est excellent ensuite nous
avons à mais je vous en prie
et ils vous installez vous voulez c'est
quand même très très stable et chez vous
un peu plus et pour terminer avant marie
renée allez-y oui et installez-vous
louis très bien bien aux est donc je
vais vous rappeler les prénoms nous
avons ici julie carle
amélie et marie renée ne leur montrais
pas donc voilà comme ça ils vont pas
être jaloux pour la fin et je vous en
prie décider c'est bon vous avez tous
les prénoms tout le monde ok vous avez
bien mélanger ça oui ok très bien vous
ce que vous allez avoir vous allez avoir
un rôle assez incroyable car ce soir
vous allez jouer le rôle de différents
phénomènes climatologiques
je m'explique vous allez décider sans
regarder de piocher une carte de devant
vous ne regardez pas laissez vous tenter
et ne regardez surtout pas la garde nous
avaient vandalisé pour une carte devant
vous mais ne le regarde absolument pas
c'est bon vous êtes vous décidé madame
le chaos oui très bien
ok donc récapitulons un peu pourquoi on
utilise un paquet mélangés par le chaos
parce que le nombre de manière de
mélanger un paquet de cartes est égal à
un nombre qui s'y créent 8 avec 63 0
derrière soi un nombre plus grand que le
nombre d'atomes sur terre peut donc
considérer que l'état du paquet tel
qu'il est peut être considérée comme un
état initial d'une météo quelque part
d'onde
ensuite nous avons les différents
phénomènes climatologiques qui ont
essayé de s'imposer en montrant leurs
grâces ou tout simplement leur
simplicité au chaos et en essayant de
représenter un phénomène vous par
exemple vous avez décidé de représenter
le pouvait montrer le roi de corps mais
vous aurez pu représenter par exemple le
cas deux carreaux ou le disque de
mais vous l'avez pas fait chacun d'entre
vous auraient pu changer d'avis mais peu
importe vos choix parce qu'au final
c'est le chaos qui décide madame le
chaos qu'ils avaient sur qui vous êtes
vous décidez vous pouvez montrer non
mais bon elle veut pas montrer elle est
démontrée à médis
amélie beaucoup qu'est ce que vous
représentez le 3 pics mais vous aurez pu
changer la vie vous auriez pu dire on
disons par exemple que julie avait l'air
beaucoup plus intelligente beaucoup plus
sincères ne seront tombés sur le le
mythe de coeur mais vous l'avez pas fait
imaginez le nombre de possibilités de
changement de choix qui aurait pu se
passer ce soir mais pour arriver à un
seul est un seul scénario amélie avec le
3 de pique
je reviens vers vous maintenant vous
savez pas trop ce qui s'est passé on est
d'accord là et vous depuis le départ
vous avez pensé à un numéro de chance
n'est ce pas et vous tenez un paquet
avec vous que vous l'avez pas ouvert un
paquet de cartes avec différents carte
avec un certain nombre de cartes au
dessus de chacune vous avez un nombre
justicier on a généré une carte
totalement aléatoirement
une carte qui sera dans ce pack est là
avec un certain nombre de cartes sud
elle voyez où je veux en venir
ça serait quand même dingue six en
comptant à votre numéro de chance la
prochaine carte soit la carte qui a été
générée aléatoirement ici n'est ce pas
parce que ça aurait pu être n'importe
quelle autre personne ou même si vous
avez donné les possibles à d'autres
personnes on aurait eu quelque chose de
totalement différent ce soir parce qu'il
aurait fait différents défilés de mode
vous pouvez ouvrir tout délicatement
vraiment faisant gaffe le paquet de
cartes faces cachées sortait toutes les
cartes dans l'ordre ne les fait pas
tomber face cachée très bien
et juste ici vous pouvez compter 18
cartes faces cachées et mettre la
prochaine juste là c'est quoi votre
numéro de chance par on le dit ok je
tisse de l'ordre comme exemple mais du
coup tombée
bref au quai du coup eu à l'époque 1 2 3
4 5 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
attendez un instant la prochaine pouvez
la mettre juste la face cachée parce que
juste imaginer un instant on est
d'accord que si vous avez pris un nombre
un peu plus grand on aurait pu avoir une
autre terre voire même quelqu'un entre
dans la salle où un nombre un petit peu
plus petit et nous ferons tomber sur le
disque de trèfle place de cas mais ici
une seule carte qui génére y est il est
sur le quai l'été la carte qui a été
générée ici le 3 pics je vous laisse
retourner
pratique merci beaucoup merci infiniment
comme d'ailleurs tous et même gardé le
trafic merci à vous tous on les
applaudit encore une dernière pour
revenir à votre place
merci infiniment merci entend garder le
3 pics en tant que souvenirs pour nous
une dernière fois pour nos personnes sur
scène merci encore voilà comment des
actions qui peuvent paraître d'abord
insignifiante peuvent avoir des
conséquences concrètes et un impact plus
grand que ce qu'on imagine sur la suite
de notre vie chacun des choix qu'ils ont
fait ce soir a été déterminant pour
parvenir à ce résultat le monde
autre choix aurait causé un résultat
totalement différent d'ailleurs si l'un
d'entre eux avait décidé d'agir
autrement ça n'aurait pas fonctionné
j'aurais honte devant beaucoup de
personnes mais ceci est applicable à
toutes les actions insignifiante et
quotidienne de notre vie de la boisson
condé chez d'acheter aux distributeurs
un autre choix entre prendre l'escalier
où l'ascenseur chacun de ces scénarios
causera un effet papillon propre et
unique
peut-être que quand vous avez réservé
votre train pour venir
si vous avez pris le train précédent ou
que vous étiez mis en seconde classe
plutôt qu'en première vous aurez fait
une rencontre qui vous aurez un
bouleverser une rencontre
professionnelle un nouvel ami ou même un
amour
d'ailleurs ma présence ici devant vous
ce soir est le résultat d'une réaction
en chaîne et d'un événement
microscopique 6 à 14 ans je n'avais pas
découvert par hasard une boîte de magie
carte
jamais je ne ferais lancé dans la magie
si en terminale un ami et moi n'avions
pas décidé de sur un coup de tête de
faire un spectacle de fin d'année de
magie jamais je n'aurais commencé à
créer le numéro les circonstances étant
pas bonne nos employés temps étaient
devenus incompatibles et le projet a été
abandonné
mais c'est précisément parce que cette
porte a été fermée que j'ai continué
d'écrire jusqu'à créé à partir d'un
unique numéro un spectacle complet si à
mon école n'y avait pas théâtre jamais
je n'aurais pu commencer à jouer mon
spectacle pour la première fois pour
ensuite le proposer un théâtre parisien
et enfin si j'avais nommé mon spectacle
imprévisible comme on était mon
intention de départ et non pas l'effet
papillon jamais l'équipe tedx loi ne
m'aurait remarquer
c'est donc grâce à une boîte de magie
carte découverte à 14 ans qui aura
retenu mon attention par hasard puisque
les casse tête que je projetais acheté
en premier lieu que je me tiens devant
vous ce soir un ensemble de plusieurs
petites décisions et circonstances sont
amenés au partage d'un instant
d'émerveillement ce soir mais si vous
n'essayez pas de vous intéresser à la
manière dont vous impacté le monde
autour de vous vous ne pourrez pas voir
la puissance de vos choix comme ce soir
si nous n'étions pas intéressés au
paquet que rester là depuis le départ
jamais il n'aurait pu réaliser
l'importance de chacun des choix des
personnes sur scène mais dès lors que
l'on prend conscience de l'impact que
peuvent avoir les petites actions on
commence à optimiser et à mieux
réfléchir nos actions nous perdons tant
de temps de notre vie a juste attendre
attendre que le feu passe au vert que la
file avance que notre tour arrive et si
au lieu de perdre ce temps limité et
précieux nous l'utilisions pour avoir un
impact positif pour aider les autres et
rien qu'à travers une simple petite
action qui elle aura un impact beaucoup
plus important
un numéro peut faire rêver pendant les
gens pendant quelques instants
une simple pièce peut changer la journée
d'un mendiant un un mot gentil ou même
un simple sourire peut suffire à
remonter le moral de quelqu'un en
dépression allard essayant de porter
attention au choix que nous faisons
réfléchissons les cas même s'il nous
paraissent insignifiants ils peuvent
avoir un retentissement insoupçonnées et
sont souvent porteurs de grands
changements merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]